this shop from 1917 shows Lance Corporal
Schofield played by George Makai running
through destroyed town and jumping off a
high ledge into a river it seems like
just one long continuous take however if
you look behind the scenes leading up to
this the camera crew had to chase after
George by Jeep motorcycle and even by
foot as the actor then jumped off a
ledge onto a mat which was cobbled
together with another shot of the
character jumping into a river this is
just one of the many crafty ways the
filmmakers made the movie look like it
is all just one single shot getting it
right required precise timing the
highest level of planning and some
incredibly clever shooting and editing
the entirety of 1917 a drama set during
World War one follows a pair of young
soldiers trying to deliver a message to
stop an attack it was not actually shot
in one take but rather a series of
continuous uncut shots that were then
cleverly connected to give the feeling
of one long take while this has been
done before 1917 presented many new
challenges for the filmmakers one of the
earliest examples of a one-shot film was
Alfred Hitchcock's rope a more recent
example is Birdman 1917 pushes it a step
further with its persistent action and
the constantly changing terrain it never
uses the same location twice who was up
for this daunting task cinematographer
Roger Deakins Deakins earned a
reputation as well the greatest
cinematographers alive today thanks to
his masterful work on movies like
Skyfall and Sicario he earned the best
cinematography Oscar for Blade Runner
2049 I mean this is not for the style of
filmmaking that is right for every film
it's very particular filming director
Sam Mendes wanted to create an immersive
experience and put the audience in the
shoes of a British soldier fighting in
World War one getting the camera right
up in the soldiers faces as they move
through long narrow trenches was a major
aspect of that first off because of all
the long takes the crew would be
shooting 1917 required even more
preparation than the average movie for
example the crew built models of every
single set like this farmhouse that the
two soldiers visit here is the model
they built and here's how it appeared in
the movie the models help the crew see
how the overall scene should look take
the scene where Scofield runs through a
destroyed city it was lit up by flares
in the sky because the flares were the
main source of lighting for certain
shots in this scene the crew needed to
time exactly how long the flares would
be in the air so they tested it on a
mini model of the city with a light
contraption that traced which directions
the shadows would move and how light
would fall through the building's
windows seeing the landscapes and sets
in person was just as important for
getting the entire continuous
down the art department built realistic
sets from scratch each set needed to be
able to accommodate the cameras path for
example the barbed wire the two soldiers
walked through in no-man's land had
angled pathway so the camera could get
through ramps allowed the camera to pass
from no-man's land into the lower German
trenches meanwhile tunnel entrances had
to be the exact right length to
accommodate the camera and their cuts
one window was built to come apart so
that the camera could pass through it
perhaps most impressive of all was the
5200 feet of trenches the crew had to
build as some of the most action-packed
and challenging shots happen in these
narrow pathways it was crucial to
measure everything every scene had to be
the exact length of the land so if a
scene shot lasted eight minutes it had
to take exactly that long to get through
that specific area in an interview with
Vox Mendez said they wouldn't fill the
set until they knew exactly how long it
should be this required a lot of
rehearsing while all films require
rehearsals the process for 1917 was much
longer and more rigorous according to
Deakins on most films these rehearsals
can take place the day of shooting
but for 1917 walkthroughs were happening
well in advance they started rehearsing
at Shepperton studios near London and
then moved to the sets every single line
of dialogue had to be rehearsed on
location the whole process of blocking
and rehearsing scenes went on for four
months once they had gotten the lay of
the land measured everything out and
made sure every actor knew their lines
and hit their marks it was time to start
shooting there was another crucial step
in pulling off this illusion the camera
could never move backward only forward
as the characters had a starting point
and a fixed destination and could never
go back one solution for that letting
the camera move 360 degrees this allowed
the crew to constantly move forward and
follow the characters without making a
visible hard cut
productions of this size call for heavy
equipment but how is the crews supposed
to deal with cameras that needed to be
mobile the solution a new model of
high-definition camera that was much
lighter and smaller than usual
this gave deacons the same great image
quality but also allowed for more
portability and for the camera to more
quickly be attached to something like a
crane or a drone a heavier camera would
not have worked with the crew
stabilizers which were crucial for when
the camera operators had to walk and run
after the soldiers creatively Sam and I
talked about it we wanted the camera to
be quite steady we didn't want a jacket
camera stuff one can understand why the
camera needed to be light as there were
cameras running along wires to capture
shots like this one where Scofield jumps
across a broken bridge the camera also
traveled on wires first trip through
no-man's land it could very easily be
unhooked from these wires by a camera
operator
Scofield's journey downriver was
captured mostly by a crane a part of the
sequence in which the character drops
down an 18-foot set of waterfalls was
shot by attaching the camera to a drone
the constant movement created another
big challenge lighting a scene they did
use some artificial lighting like this
50-foot tall light tower that was dimmed
to create the color of fire and meant to
light up the entire wound village
however if they put lights in the
trenches they might accidentally show up
on screen during one of the movies many
360-degree shots so they relied mostly
on natural light cloudy days were more
optimal than sunny days as sunny days
meant more shadows coming I'm looking at
all my weather apps to see when it's
gonna cloud over and then is that cloud
gonna last long enough to do a 5-minute
take and because the movie took place in
real time the lighting had to look
consistent even a little too much Sun in
the sky men's production had to shut
down for the day
Deacon's needed to know not just how
shots would look but how they would be
stitched together in post-production
deacons and Mendez found subtle ways to
make those cuts without the audience
knowing this would also help editor Lee
Smith immensely
sometimes an object would block the
frame shots where characters travel
through doorways or entered a bunker
also allowed for easier cuts take this
shot where the two main characters walk
through a black curtain other shots
required even cleverer transitions in
one filling sequence Scofield runs
through a burning City and jumps off a
ledge into a river if you look at the
same shot behind the scenes you'll see
George running through that same city
and jumping off the ledge but instead of
a river he jumps onto a mat with the
help of some visual effects the editors
were able to seamlessly stitch together
the character jumping off the ledge and
into the rapids and to capture him even
getting to that point the camera crew
had to make sure they were completely in
sync with the actors every movement some
parts of the maze-like sequence involved
chasing after him with a camera attached
to a motorcycle for the big leap they
needed to attach a camera to a longer
more flexible crane but nothing quite
matched the challenge of pulling off the
climactic sequence in which Scofield
runs alongside a trench in the middle of
battle getting the shot was a huge
endeavor we started on a 50-foot Technic
rain that was armed in from say as we're
facing Jorge from the right hand side it
climbs up the trench with him as the
cameras booming out on the arm he
hesitates at the top of the trench then
the cameras taken off that Technic rain
because the cameras basically on a
stabilized head called a stable I
surprise surprise and they hook it onto
another Technic rain and that Technic
rain is on the back of a tracking
vehicle and that's already slowly moving
back so as they hook it on it's all one
move that moves back Jorge speeds up and
starts running meanwhile the two grips
that did that are in costume so they
find a way around to be able to come
across the back of the shot and you
don't see them until that point in
costume and that they were quite glad
because they got
money for being extras that day once the
camera was on the truck it had to follow
George as he ran for about a quarter of
a mile meanwhile they had explosions
going on in the background
according to Deacons they only had
enough explosions for four tanks and
thanks to their tireless rehearsals and
walk throughs they were able to pull it
off on time and while everything they
did while shooting had to be so precise
there was still room for accidents as
George is running out of the trench
you'll see him bump into some extras
that wasn't planned the actor bumped
into them by accident and they just kept
the camera rolling had they called cut
right away this great genuine moment
capturing the chaos of the war would
never have made it into the movie